johnny 80 asks
the abduction happened around 1975 and
our technology was still primitive at
the time
during your time inside the ship what
kind of devices or interfaces got your
attention what did the light sources
look like were there any screen or any
thing that displays images
oh yeah there was a great deal of uh
of that sort of thing that i wasn't
there
uh gee whiz wow this is amazing i was
terrified it was out of my mind how do i
get out of this thing how do i escape
was my main focus so
so
most of the um
you know
um
interest in these kinds of things
occurred in retrospect you know looking
back on
uh
things i saw and interpreting them
the best i could
is there anything now that
much technology has been developed in
the past 40 years
whereas before you wouldn't recognize
what a cell phone was
maybe it wouldn't be conspicuous to you
or just wouldn't register but now you
have that so now thinking back given our
technology is there something that you
recognize that when you were there you
didn't but now you have this linguistic
toolset of modern technology
yeah um and maybe things beyond still
where we are you know uh what was
i described as a screen
had intersecting lines
but no characters and that's really
strange how would they know what was
what as far as these gradations
meant it's all speculation
is it alright if i ask you some
questions about the screen
uh well
like
like i'm saying i was just
desperate to find a way to open the door
and escape this thing and i
wasn't musing about what this means it
was a um
just
a glowing surface kind of like a
computer but um
black lines
with little
short
black lines on each of those but at
angles
and these
angles would change and they would slide
in response to
me touching this uh surface
i i took to be buttons it was some
colored areas on the surface
i don't remember have you ever mentioned
this before i was looking at some of
your interviews i don't recall this
well i might have just referred to them
as buttons your this is much more in
depth in that area than i've ever
encountered
have you ever drawn it before
um
no
i worked with an artist who just
uh gave a more distant shot
uh angle of um
um you know like from the door from a
distance
okay so
you might understand at this point you
were lying down when you saw the screen
no no i was wandering around
desperately seeking a way out
okay so from what i understand just
correct me if i'm wrong you were you
woke up
being
finding it difficult to breathe someone
put a mask on you that didn't seem to be
attached to anything it also calmed you
at some point someone who looked human
appeared to you
and i believe they started taking you
out of this smaller room into a larger
one is that correct
oh well uh
no
that's pretty i'll jumble together you
know i woke up um
and very great deal of pain
um
when i could finally focus and see these
creatures standing over me i realized no
i
hadn't been hurt and sent to a hospital
but uh i was taken out of this craft by
human looking beings
to this larger room and
smaller room off of that
um
that's where the mask was applied but
that was basically just designed to uh
put me out uh make render me unconscious
there are three rooms in total there's
the one that you were initially in the
one that you exited and it was much
larger and you said there was an alcohol
that's a vast over simplification i was
inside the craft when i finally exited
that it was at that point parked inside
of this huge we'll call it a room it
could be a building or part of a larger
craft
and then taken out of this big huge
hangar-like area
uh down a hallway
to the room where i was rendered
unconscious
were you able to see outside the craft
what color were the walls if there were
walls
um the
i
i took the
um
lighted areas
in the big hanger like area to be
the sunlight being filtered through some
kind of uh
uh frosted surface but it also could
have been um
synthetically or you know
produced artificially produced uh
something to duplicate sunlight
just uh
not super intense but just enough to
light the area
you also just mentioned that you were
working with an artist
did the artist draw those lines on the
screen that you're referring to about
five minutes ago
well i described it to him but uh the
overall lay of the room and
you know
the the the screen and the surfaces that
it was mounted on all that was
you know a
a
20 feet away sort of uh perspective not
down over my shoulder watching my hand
kind of perspective that's what i was
trying to tell you do you have a pen and
paper in front of you
within arm's reach yeah
remember i said that i love details
do you mind showing me some of the
lines on the screen because as you were
describing them i can't visualize what
you're saying you're saying there's some
lines and lines coming off but there are
no markings
to indicate certain positions
well i'm no artist but
this screen
you saw it
where within
the ship
uh it was mounted on the arm of the of a
chair
um
it's just long uh lines
with short lines
but they didn't have numbers on each of
the little
short lines
and they would move in response to
things i did yeah i see it
but
didn't reveal any information to me i
mean
so they moved in response to you you
didn't get the sense that that was a map
of something else it actually was
congruent with your emotions so when you
turned
the signals changed
well that's a possibility too
and tim has one last question travis do
you recall seeing any symbols signs or
writings on the walls floor ceilings
etc
good question but uh no
no symbols of any kind
no numbers no letters
or anything that would
suggest such a thing